the Joe Rogan experience and they might
I mean there's something to it because
those were BJ's best days the Sean Sherk
fight the Diego Sanchez fight that was
prime BJ Penn when he was the
[ __ ] of [ __ ] that was
what was up I mean he was she was
training with the miranda [ __ ] did
you did you see that video him beatin of
the bouncer he was obviously having a
real tough time man
I didn't I just saw the video I don't
know how it was just inside control with
flip-flops on yeah but here's my thing I
don't know the situation I led to it I
only saw that he's on top of the guy and
I'm like and I'm like this isn't Hawaii
like who picks a fight with BJ Penn in
Hawaii or who even like steps to BJ Penn
in Hawaii I mean I understand if there
was I don't know the situation if it's
like DJ you got to leave and he's not
listening you try to get BJ's friends to
go play talk to your guy man get him out
of here but like you know you'll go toe
to toe BJ pad alright it seems stupid
choice I don't care
hey did max Holloway is he the one who
started the bottle cap challenge do we
know that for a fact he's the first one
I saw
I'm so tired of seeing people kick
bottle caps I saw I was gonna say
there's something different about his is
that the cap stayed on the bottle
everyone else is just kicking the cap
off
spinning coincidental I know but that
that might be to the bottle of Tito's I
think that he used but like that's a
little more impressive than some of the
other people just knock that offer
slightly slightly if it's not that big
of a listen there's a reason why so many
people are doing it it's not that hard
it's just not that hard you throw a
wheel kick like this you just like get
someone to hold it you get someone to
hold tight and the wheel kick goes like
this and you have the bottle cap barely
on so the bottle cap is like this hey
just make sure you throw wheel kick like
that but you don't knock it off that's
everyone else knock it off he kept it on
well I think people using water bottle
caps which have a shallow
set of grooves whereas like the bottle
that he used has a deeper good it'd be
more impressive if they showed the whole
bottle and that there's not someone
holding it you like you only I think
I've never even thought once about doing
it like I know how to throw a wheel kick
I'm not gonna do that
it seems silly to me like with Jason
Statham's do it and when John Mayer did
it the [ __ ] shark was jumped was it
that assassin I think max called him out
on it he did it yeah he called out John
Mayer why it's like why does Justin
Bieber want to fight Tom Cruise there's
so many questions
III would watch it I would I think Tom
Cruise will and lock him up with all
those crazy voodoo superpowers he got
from Scientology and the aliens belief
in himself
[Applause]